10 heures ce jeudi matin le château de
montpoupon en indre-et-loire rouvre ses
portes après deux mois et demi de
fermeture forcée depuis sa vitre de
plexiglas l'hôtesse d'accueil explique à
ses tout premiers visiteurs
les nouvelles règles pour parcourir les
lieux les corps ces règles à observer
condition sinequanone pour pouvoir
accueillir à nouveau le public ont été
harmonisées à l'échelle régionale et à 8
août un référentiel qui a été élaboré et
mis en place par les sites du val de
loire avec un travail commun avec la
région centre val de loire pour établir
un référentiel de mesures sanitaires
avec un protocole est élaboré par
exemple on peut le voir les espaces
d'accueil avec ce plexiglas au niveau
des personnes à l'accueil on et munis de
masques des marquages au sol pourrait
également avoir une distanciation un
nombre de personnes par différentes
pièces par exemple ici dans cet espace
d'accueil on peut
recevoir quatre personnes maximum à la
fois situé au coeur de la touraine ce
château privé date du moyen-âge
il abrite un parc et un musée qui
s'étend sur 30 salle dédiée à l'univers
de la vénerie du cheval et de l'art
depuis 1857 il est habité par la même
famille qui s'inquiètent aujourd'hui des
conséquences économiques de la crise
sanitaire vous donner un exemple il ya
un site qui a ouvert le week-end dernier
et ils ont eu 33 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires de l'année dernière sur le
week end
ils ont eu 7 % en semaine donc c'est
quand même catastrophique
c'est catastrophique la limitation de la
distance de 100 km et quand même à
l'agglo aux syndicats ainsi que les
frontières sont fermées parce que c'est
quand même une grande partie de tous et
des gens d'une heure d'une jambe
belgique de hollande angleterre qui
viennent visiter la france et surtout
des gros week-end comme celui ci de
quatre jours un manque à gagner
conséquent pour les propriétaires des
lieux les visiteurs régionaux ne
constituent que 30% de son affluence
habituelle